c'est le mec il dit à son pote il dit
[ __ ] je me suis tailladé les couilles
en me rasant les les poils ah merde
j'ai pris mon téléphone toi pour me
servir de miroir puis j'ai commencé à
recevoir des likes
[Applaudissements]
au revoir on voit qu'on est en dernière
partie d'émission
quand même
Samuel c'est un mec qui va chez son
médecin il lui dit docteur j'ai un
problème hier je la semaine dernière je
suis rentré chez moi un peu plus tôt et
j'ai vu ma femme dans mon lit avec mon
voisin je suis parti dans la cuisine
j'ai pris un couteau je vais les tranché
les deux je vais me trancher la gorge et
là docteur un self control docteur je
pose le couteau je ferme le tiroir je me
fais un petit café je réfléchis 5
minutes lendemain rebelote je reviens un
peu plus tôt qui je vois dans mon lit ma
femme avec mon voisin et mon cousin
germain là je suis parti prendre le
pistolet je me dis je vais buter tout le
monde et m'envoyer une balle j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] et là docteur un chef
contrôle docteur
je pose le pistolet je ferme le tiroir
je me fais un petit café je réfléchis 5
minutes le lendemain rebelote je viens
chez moi un peu plus tôt qui je vois
dans mon lit ma femme le voisin est le
concierge d'en bas je vais dans le
garage je me prends le fusil je vais
fusiller tout le monde et je m'envoies
une balle et là docteur un chef contrôle
donc je pose le fusil sur le tiroir je
me fais un petit café je réfléchis 5
minutes et alors dites-moi docteur c'est
pas dangereux pour ma santé tous ces
petits cafés
[Applaudissements]
en Belgique nous en été on a un peu
comment dire c'est pas une tradition
mais un truc un peu drôle dans les fêtes
les Belges les femmes belges à la fin
des soirées elle s'assaient sur les
barbecues
des moules frites
[Applaudissements]
et que sa femme il a entendu bruit dans
l'armoire disons
il ouvre il ouvre l'armoire il voit un
mec à poil dans l'armoire il dit
Monsieur
tu comprends le mec il dit Monsieur
qu'est-ce que vous faites là vas-y je
chasse les mythes
[Musique]
à poil et l'autisme regarde comme ça
Dieu [ __ ] ah bon déjà tout bouffé
[Applaudissements]
et sa femme ben voilà elle dit écoute
mon mari j'ai besoin voilà que ça se
passe qui est quelque chose qui se passe
j'aimerais bien que j'accepte ma
proposition ah bon mais c'est quoi ta
proposition je comprends pas moi tu sais
je suis très religieux et tout qu'est-ce
qui se passe ben j'aimerais qu'il y ait
un bel étalon qui soit avec nous un
homme de 25 ans bien baraqué et tout
pendant qu'on fait l'amour ah bon mais
qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'il te fasse bah
j'ai pas de l'air de l'éventail ok bon
ça va bah monsieur ben Toussain on y va
il commence il positionne le mec de 25
ans devant lui avec cet éventail lui dit
écoute je fais bien le jugement tu vends
du vent ma femme elle a envie d'être au
frais ok il y a pas de problème et tout
et commence par la toucher etc ça y va
et puis là elle lui dit que ça marche
vraiment pas je comprends pas qui se
passe je sais pas je pense qu'il
faudrait qu'on switch ah bon mais
pourquoi qu'on switch et ben parce que
je sais pas viens on essaye je te dis
l'homme de 25 ans prend la place de
Monsieur ben Toussain Bensoussan il
prend l'éventail il fait de l'air un
coup un véritable il passe et là elle
hurle ah
et là Monsieur Benson il regarde le mec
il lui dit tu vois c'est pas si
compliqué de faire de l'air
très bien doucement
[Applaudissements]
également chez vous
voilà bon alors c'est le fils de
cette Alicia le fils d'un monsieur Corse
et dans la famille c'est très difficile
d'avoir eu quelqu'un qui a eu le
baccalauréat alors le père de ma fille
est dit bon mon fils je suis content tu
as réussi à avoir le rattrapage le bac à
l'oral
je suis mais vraiment émotionné fermer
cette porte le soir
le soir le soir le soir elle a commencé
le 4 jours
le père toute la journée il est stressé
il est stressé qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
mon fils qu'est-ce qu'il va faire mon
fils donc le soir il rentre
le fils et lui dit dis-moi dis-moi mon
fils comment ça s'est passé papa tu vas
être fier de moi vraiment tu vas être
fier de moi c'est le top et raconte-moi
ce document
interrogé pendant deux heures je n'ai
rien dit
merci merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme ça et il dit moi je voudrais un
whisky et je paye pas parce que j'ai
peur de personne
mec il a un petit le patron de marine un
peu petit et tout comme ça le mec est
grand et tout fais chier [ __ ] bon
whisky l'autre il boit son whisky
lendemain rebelote le métier là moi je
voudrais un whisky je paye pas parce que
j'ai peur de personne
il appelle un pote il attend j'ai un mec
qui me fait chier tous les jours ça fait
deux fois qui vient déjà il a peut-être
son pote le plus bas est-ce qu'il existe
le plus balais que 2 mètres 125 kg une
masse vas-y viens Jojo tu t'attends le
mec troisième jour Jojo il est là bas
le mec qui arrive moi je veux un verre
de whisky je paye pas parce que j'ai
peur de personne bah Jojo il se retourne
fais-moi non plus j'ai peur de personne
j'adore
s'il arrive en Ferrari il arrive en
Ferrari devant le bistrot il prend son
petit café laisse la voiture dehors tu
vois il boit son café il paye ça et il
s'est passé qui est plus les clés
de sa Ferrari toi rentre dans le bar
il dit bon
je vais compter jusqu'à 3
les clés de ma Ferrari sinon
je ferai exactement ce que mon
grand-père a fait il y a 20 ans tout le
monde est comme ça
au moment où il veut dire c'est moi
c'est moi
les clés et puis il raccompagne la
voiture il dit juste pour savoir vous
nous avez fait tellement peur
il avait fait quoi il y a 20 ans votre
grand-père dit il était rentré à pied
[Applaudissements]
connu sous le nom de emrata elle fait
une tournée en Europe et elle a invité
au Vatican elle a reçu par le pape
François elle lui fait visiter la
chapelle Sixtine tout ça un moment le
pape lui présente un classeur et il dit
regardez comme vous voulez mannequins on
a un bouc avec tous les books tous les
bébés prêtres d'Europe alors ça c'est le
prêt de Paris très gentil ça c'est le
prêt de Varsovie très gentil et ça c'est
le prêtre de Turin et elle voit le prêt
de Turin sublime une petite bouche en
cœur de Cyril Hanouna le mec
et elle lui dit mais lui il est prête
oui oui exactement il est prête et tu
rincé loin elle va il dit non tu rinces
à deux heures elle sort du Vatican elle
prend la voiture et bah tu rends elle
voit l'église comme ça elle rentre dans
l'église elle le voit elle est encore
plus beau que sur la photo elle lui dit
toi là-bas fais moi l'amour il dit quoi
fais moi l'amour il dit non mais
Seigneur c'est quoi cette tentation que
tu m'envoies elle enlève la robe comme
ça vas-y baisse moi baisse moi sur les
bancs il se retourne il se retourne vers
Jésus qui Jésus et qu'est-ce que je dois
faire Jésus est comme ça il dit
détachement [ __ ] je me la faire
[Applaudissements]